حرب كلاميه بين تويتر ومتى شمها ايلون
ماسك ضد تطبيق وتساب ماسك نسخ متابعيه
الذين يقاربون 140 مليون متابع ممن يقراون
تغريداته بعدم الوثوق بتطبيق واتساب ايضا
اضافه ماسك بتغريدته على فيديو نشره فؤاد
دبيريه مدير القسم الهندسي بتويتر
محذرا من ان واتساب كان يستخدم مايكروفون
الهاتف للتنصت عليه واتساب رد بتغريده
بقاله مؤكده ان امكانيه التحكم الكامل في
اعدادات الميكروفون الخاصه
بالمستخدمين لكن ماسك كعاده ونشر صوره
الميكروفون بشكل متكرر وقال لا يمكن
الوثوق بواتساب اب ولا باي شيء حتى بلا
شيء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات